all right well thank you everybody for
coming to sterling Memorial Library
today for Beyond Boundaries which is the
second annual symposium on hybrid
scholarship that you this is the second
year that we put on this symposium and
the woman who's been the real organizer
of this is Katherine DeRose who many in
the room they know as the engagement and
outreach manager for the digital
humanities lab Katherine is often the
first person that people see when they
walk into the lab and she's also
responsible for the emails that many of
you get or will get after you have
signed in this morning as well as our
social media presence
so as we kick off beyond boundaries to I
just like to take a moment to
acknowledge the work of Catherine Durant
[Applause]
and I'd also like to take a moment to
acknowledge the work with Manik on Reid
who's the user experience designer in
the digital humanities lab and is
responsible for the second year in a row
for our beautiful logo and visual
identity so Thank You Monica so before
we begin today's events I just want to
say a couple of brief remarks and those
sort of Center on my own experiences
Beyond Boundaries this to the second
year and I think the thing that really
stays with me from the first year we put
this on and I'm sure will be continuous
in the second year is that this is
really a great event for two reasons the
first reason is that it brings people
from across the many campuses that Yale
has the science area of the traditional
core West Campus even the hospital and
more than just physical location it also
brings people together from all sorts of
different units that are represented on
this program so if you look at the names
in the program you all receive you look
at the department you're going to see
affiliations ranging from English to
cognitive science the engineering
science to the Babylonian collection the
Department of Music I think that's
really great that this event drink
brings in so many people from so many
different disciplines institutes and
centers across campus and the second
thing that stays with me from the first
year and it's also represented in this
the program for the second year is that
this is an event that brings together
folks at all different levels of
scholarship we have of course some
professors who are going to speak today
we have a distinguished curators visual
collections and physical collections we
have an amazing cohort of graduate
students are going to be talking about
their work and we also have most
importantly a bunch of folks from Yale
College who are going to be presenting
today and also going to be showing some
of their work in the poster session at
the end of this event that's really what
stays with me from these two years that
we've done this event is the sort of
cross-disciplinary nature and also the
way that this event tries to bring
together folks at all different varying
levels at the University I also want to
acknowledge the sport of on to families
and groups that have been very important
to support of
and digital humanities on campus we have
the day in the room rich Frankie will be
joined shortly by Barbara Frankie
who supports for many units of the
university and specifically the library
has it really wonderful over the years
and that support is continuing with
their generosity to enable the digital
humanities lab to have a wonderful new
home in a beautiful reading room the
Frankie family reading room in the next
calendar year so thanks very much to
rich and Barbara Frankie
[Applause]
and also I want to acknowledge the
support of the goyda Family Foundation
whose generosity has enabled the first
three years of the digital humanities
lab on the OU campus and its support for
hybrid scholarship and steam on campus
so thanks very much LIGO equative
foundation and with that i'd like to
kick off our round of lightning talk so
i'm going to be introducing each person
or team member as they approach and on
the first is of Masha Shmuel Berg and
Andrew Vulcan who are PhD students in
respectively complet and someone media
studies as well as art history and film
and Media Studies Andrew - hi everyone
so thank you thank you Peter for
introducing us
I'll let Andrew kick us off hello
everyone thanks for coming so to begin I
would say last year Masha and I had the
privilege of participating in a
year-long initiative sponsored by the
mellon foundation on inquiring into the
various techniques that we use for
digital humanities we spend a year
exploring a lot of the different
techniques that we could possibly be
applying for home discipline of film
studies and so over this year-long
endeavor we were diligently trying to
see like what gaps existed within our
discipline and how digital tools could
be used to fill them and so the one
thing we stumbled across was what we
noticed how much interest it was in our
field into uncovering the various
distribution networks and channels of
films and uncovering how they of films
cross borders and now we might see we
might also unpack the distribution
channels and a lot of nations are not
really part of the hegemonic Western
Canon and so the project we project we
formulated together called cine circuits
where we really focus on the that's
explosive proliferation of the
International Film Festival and the
phase one of our project which was also
generously funded by the digital
humanities lab
for its development focuses on how film
festivals proliferate over time and so
with with the seed grant we received
from the lab we were able to go through
the various indexes online various
databases of the film festivals and
there are thousands of film festivals
that are in existence right now and I
put a lot of resources are fragmented
and not easily indexed and so our prior
task our project is essentially a Big
Data project was to consolidate all this
big data all this information put into
our own database work through it and
then geo-reference everything so that it
could be mapped into an interactive
website using the online web-based
software program called cartodb now
known as Carta and so our website will
feature a mapping interface that makes a
lot of this information more accessible
and so users will be able to play with
it and notice their own trends to make
observations about the film festivals
and I should add that we've been very
lucky towards with an undergraduate
admission hire who's in the computer
science program and has been helping us
with a lot of the coding the website
isn't available yet but I brought some
visuals just to explain a little bit of
what we've been doing so basically we
spent the whole year so far coming up
with an API code and that would enable
us to get information offline to create
a kind of fundamental database of all
festivals and then once we did that we
started thinking okay how can we sort
through this data to cut through it to
come up with some significant research
and so I just want to present two short
little findings we thought something
really fun would be to try to figure out
when did certain genres of cinema really
take off because that's something you
can do when you have this amount of data
and so we saw horror film festivals you
know who I not something a little bit
fun and so we compiled the database
support film festivals we were curious
to learn that they only really kick off
in 1981 which is interesting and we also
looked at children's film festivals
which give us a little bit earlier in
1961 and so part of what we want to do
is there's been a kind of a the dominant
paradigm for understanding film
festivals and then that of national
cinemas right
and so part of what we're trying to do
is to break the national cinema paradigm
to think about films of the
transnational
constantly moving same and so here's a
video that we made so one second of this
video is a 28 second video it's equal to
every two years from 1961 to 2016 and so
this shows the proliferation of
children's film festivals around the
world and as you'll see they start off
in Europe and there's kind of a lull and
then there's more and more
and so basically something that we were
able and here's a zoomin on Europe
because there's so many European
festivals
and so something that kind of became
interesting and apparent to us is we
thought that we would see if they've
cold war dynamics that would somehow be
determining right where these festivals
were but in effect a lot of the war in
middle in middle Europe in these kind of
middle zones so the Czech Republic the
Netherlands etc and the second thing
that we noticed in addition to the
geographical kinds of findings we can
find is also these temporal golden eras
so the golden era for the children's
film festival ends up being 1991 to 2006
which was also very interesting and so
once we get these kinds of small
findings we can start thinking about the
different forces shaping the festival
circuits and shaping contemporary cinema
and so this is the map of horror film
festivals
and again there's one in a big long
and so something interesting about
horror film festivals is that even
though they start off in Europe they're
really big in North America and not at
all big for example in the form of
Eastern European countries right you
don't see any there you see very few in
South America and so we're able to think
about different kinds of cultural
dynamics by being able to process this
amount of data in this way
thank you
[Applause]
so good morning everyone my name is
hieronymus I'm a junior psychology major
and today I'm going to be talking about
media trends and mental health how we
use the New York Times API to track word
use surrounding mental illness and so
going into this project my research
mentor and I were curious about two
questions like how frequently do people
talk about months of health and mental
illness throughout history in the media
and how do those rates of word use
compare between specific types of mental
illness versus earth and between mental
versus physical illness and so to do
this we use the New York Times article
search API we use this particular New
York Times API for two reasons because
we thought that the New York Times is
like a pretty popular newspaper and so
it would be fairly representative as a
sample of what the news media in
particular points in history would be
talking about and the second reason is
because it's just a very well developed
API has a lot of resources and so this
API has a database of over 16 million
articles that are sourced from the New
York Times itself
routers and The Associated Press going
all the way back to 1851 so to get the
data from this API from this database we
had to use a Python script to make the
JSON call to the API with our search
parameters or search terms and then we
got back this specific data on headlines
we got the abstract keywords web URLs
and there was a lot of other data that
could be get and so after after we made
the Python script we used it to query
for our specific search terms and these
search terms could be like mental
illness and we could also use modifiers
that we could be like veterans and PTSD
veterans and PTSD but not Iraq and so we
got the data on how many articles per
year contain the term and then we
plotted the percentage of articles by
year using our
and by percentage of articles that the
number of articles that contain our
search term divided by the total number
of articles for that year on any topic
and so using this method we wrote a
correspondence paper to an article
originally in The Lancet psychiatry so
this like psychiatrist in the UK talked
about how people nowadays are replacing
the word mental health with mental
illness out of political correctness or
whatever it is so people would say like
mental health concerns mental health
issues instead of mental illness and
that's problematic he argued that's
problematic because it's downgrades the
severity of mental illness and treats it
as like a mental an issue instead of
like illness and so we thought yeah
that's that certainly is a problem we
wanted to know more about the problem
and like when this shift in the usage of
language like mental health and mental
illness when that happened so that's
what we did using our New York Times API
tool and this is what we found so the
red line is mental house and the blue
line is mental illness as you can see
like mental health has always been used
more frequently in that in a greater
percentage of articles use the word
mental health than mental illness and
it's been this way since 1940 and as
opposed to one word replacing the other
both of them are correlated the
correlation coefficient was something
like point seven five and that just goes
to show like it actually wasn't like
mental health isn't replacing mental
illness it's just always been used more
frequently and so yeah we responded to
that paper and using our data we backed
up that claim like what you're saying
from your observations like isn't
actually backed up by data from the like
news media and so we also
happen to compare the word use and rate
of mental illness mental illness or
mental illness mental health or
behavioral health and compare it with
mentions of diabetes and hypertension so
we just wanted to know like in the news
media what do people talk about what is
popular as a disease to talk about and
mental health and illness um well it is
very broad category so it encompasses
like depression because II like a lot of
mental illnesses but it is more popular
than diabetes as a topic and
hypertension so why should you care
about this what are the implications I
think that like frequency of term usage
and being able to know how often people
use words in the media is relevant to
any humanities field because you can see
like um you can see how often people are
using it in newspapers and then you get
a reflection of how often words are
being used in the general public and
besides the New York Times there is
there also ap is for the Guardian NPR in
Bloomberg and these are also like
well-developed api's that function
similarly and you might be wondering
like what's the difference between what
we did and like google books and grams
but the difference is that we just have
more customizability
with our process and we also get access
to newspapers which I think reflects the
general public's um consumption better
than the scientific articles or the
books that might be more obscure that
are reflected by n grams and so besides
that hits we also got access to article
content like I said before we got the
headlines we got the abstract and we got
the web URL so one we just really
scratched the tip of the iceberg with
this project because we could have gone
in another direction and that is to do
sentiment analysis on the articles
themselves so what we were thinking but
didn't actually do is we could have used
the web URLs to scrape the articles
bodies and then parse the article bodies
to
whether something was talking about the
topic positively or negatively they can
give us sentiment analysis give the
score for how positive or negative an
article is based on the words they use
and so yeah I would like to think I'm
check rude he's my research mentor RPI
Greg McCarthy and our advisor dr. John
crystal and here's the references paper
that we wrote that the figures came from
and here's the github repo with our
Python tools so anyone could go on there
and recreate what we did thank you
[Applause]
thanks so much
and I now have a pleasure introducing
Kim Andrews is going to be speaking on
everything is joan baez networking
counterculture thanks so much
and thank you so much for coming it's
great to see all of you here so my topic
is actually a more about pedagogy really
than anything else so just to prepare
you for that so last semester Professor
John Williams using the also in the
English department and I sat down to try
and figure out how we might integrate
digital humanities components into a
lecture style course on the American
counterculture in the 1960s and 70s
English 195 as a lecture course such
integration was bound to come with a few
challenges particular to the class
format learning across sections would
have to be standardized in some way and
a certain amount of lecture time would
have to be devoted to skills training
without overshadowing the literary
content of the course
this time crunchiness as we know is one
of the major hurdles that anyone working
in d.h has to find a way to jump over in
our case I was one with most time and
suddenly started perhaps
counter-intuitively with me taking the
folks at the th lab at their very
generous word I had applied some
fellowship knowing very little about d-h
methods but I was generally familiar
with network graph that looked like
hairballs and topic maps that look like
acid trips acid trips would have fits
the theme of the course quite well but
we didn't have a secondary corpus to
work with we just had the syllabus so I
got to work trying to figure out what we
might do with the corpus we had that is
the collection of writers and thinkers
that our students would be reading and
writing and thinking with etc using
gessie which is a network visualization
tool I made a map of the syllabus itself
which wound up looking like this you
can't see this very well but it doesn't
really matter as you can sort of see the
course readings wound up being split
between like two and half groups right
there's a beat centered one which is
centered on Allen Ginsberg just like up
the top there's all the orange lines are
the connection there is the Naropa
universe or Norwood like Jack Kerouac
school disembodied school disembodied
poetics
in Colorado and there is another little
group which is like over there on the
far side centered on Thomas Pynchon and
all the green lines there that's just
reading relationships they know either
may or may not have known each other
personally and then there's this huge
group right big huge blob of
philosophers and writers and scientists
connected by their affiliation with the
excellent Institute in California and
those are all the pink kind of purpley
pink line so you can see their doors
fence around Timothy Leary etc right
what a visualization like this does
which is what we found out in class is
to give the students an interesting kind
of insight into how we as teachers build
our courses in this case John's interest
in a very particular West Coast centered
version of the American counterculture
became clear in a way that would have
unfolded more slowly or perhaps less
usefully or perhaps not at all without
the fact of the graph it also allowed us
to think about writing projects that
might incorporate this kind of broad
thinking about core structure and to
that end we developed a final project
for the class that involve asking
students to research a figure that
wasn't on the syllabus but could have
been and to make their case in the form
of a dedicated course press website
thank you very much Tripp Kirkpatrick in
order to facilitate this kind of
syllabus level thinking I decided to do
two things one to make a data entry
worksheet for students to fill out and
two to use that student generated data
to make a new syllabus network with all
of their figures incorporated into it I
did the first thing in order to give
students a taste of what data entry for
native for networking software looked
and felt like without overwhelming them
a facet of learning digital tools that I
think tends to get overlooked when we
talk about integrating these sorts of
technologies into humanities classrooms
here's what that looks like right this
is what I have to do obviously not with
Batman in gessie people and things get
turned into numbers and you can see that
on the on the worksheet that the
software uses to plot the network and
there's a column for the nature of the
relationship or the connection that you
can also fill in so my version of the
skill
this network which I did on my own right
looked a bit like this so this is this
is what the actual Excel spreadsheet
looks like right so you can see the nose
of the people there Jimmy did decide to
do gender and then profession and then
the connections right so they turn into
numbers undirected and then the method
of the nature bridge tip so that one is
two friendships they read English at
brunch at the dinner right in guess II
no wait sorry so you'll notice that on
the worksheet however I didn't give any
instruction so you can see I didn't
actually give them any instructions as
to what kind of connections counted as
connections between the students figures
and the syllabus or how many to find or
how many words to use or whatever I
didn't do any bet so as a result the
data I got looked like this all right so
you just you have everything here from
actual friendships to referenced in a
painting subtitle this looks like a
disaster and in some ways it is I hadn't
thought about consistency across
multiple students doing data entry and
so of course you get a mess like this
but in hindsight if I had to change it I
wouldn't the messiness produced a graph
that was instructionally misleading
because one student working on joan baez
had interpreted connection really
loosely and had thus found a relatively
large number of connections we wound up
with a new syllabus visualization in
which Joan Baez was the center of the
universe
obviously this is not an accurate
representation of how everyone and
everything being researched to read in
the class was connected but it is an
accurate representation of discrepancies
and assignment interpretation and that
is interesting on its own ultimately the
students produce course press sites that
obviously oh that that absorbs some of
the work that I've been doing semi
behind-the-scenes one student for
instance made an analogue version of a
network graph of the movie and hair
advice which was hilarious right so that
was like and one student produce a
wildly nonlinear series of vignettes
about David Foster Wallace this was very
cool were just like there were like
eight million links in this course press
type the discussions about the course as
a course which helps to produce these
projects would have been nearly
unthinkable without some way of bird's
eye view enough I am for better for
worse still a big believer in actually
reading individual attacks themselves
carefully as part of a holistic way of
helping students think about their
courses not as sets of readings handed
down to them from on high
but as list of possibilities put
together by fellow humans I am all about
messy data bad graphs and lengths of
strength thank you
[Applause]
[Applause]
great thank you very much
our next speaker will be job Sankofa
who's going to be speaking on delinquent
migrations masking black itinerant
youths labor and incarceration in
California from 1929 to 1939 hello
everyone
first my thanks DHL that for a Sea Grant
and also like phenomenal undergraduate
student who helped me Serena Lau who
helped me with the data internet mapping
and so delinquent migration is a part of
a larger project to look at kind of
public migrations that occur and the
post-emancipation era all the way up
until World War two and so this chapter
traces the lives of seven young black
males who left home between the age of
nine years old to start working up until
the age of 15 and so I'm going to scroll
through the first six and I'm going to
do a micro history of one of the
individuals and so this website is
incorporated also with like like
documentary and so I must grow past that
so and so this right here are several
young people and as you can see the
earliest left in 1896 and some of these
are were all of these people were so
seven young people as we can see
typically migration stories are like one
place to another or one place to this
but they don't sort of show the
unsettledness of some people's migration
story and so as we can see here this
young man Joseph Harvey at 8 years old
both his parents died at nine years old
he was taking them by family and he ran
away at nine years old and began working
and following race stay was as an
exercise boy and so he ends up going
through New Orleans to New York and ends
up in the American West by like age 15
and ended up going to prison for
something he didn't do and so partly
what I'm trying to do here is also so
that what differs between young people's
migration story
is a lot of times to push for factors
and so typically the great migration
story is about fathers mothers families
leaving going from one place to the
other heads of households but it's never
from the narrative of young people who
were displaced who ran away or who were
actually running away from their home
and terror in their home and so this
young man he left home at age 14 and as
you can see this map follows him almost
he's in his 40s and as you can see the
first red line is the first place that
he goes and he's born in Carthage Texas
and he leaves home at 14 and as you can
see he was a little bit everywhere okay
and so this other person Willie cannon
was born in 1900 and both Arkansas and
he left and he actually went to the
Midwest first he went to st. Louis then
he went to Chicago and he left on May 14
as well and so he goes to Iowa and then
he goes to the west and as you can see
he goes back to Arkansas and then he
goes back to California and from there
ends up running into the law and having
a hard time eventually and so this
person was born in Tennessee he goes to
Detroit so it's 12 years old this person
his mother died when he was 11 his
father put him out of Twitter so oh they
said he had to fend for himself and so
at 12 years old he went all the way to
Detroit and I tried managing like 12
years old leaving home going to Detroit
and then started his journey going to
Chicago and then as you can see goes
back to Tennessee and eventually on his
way out west he's charged with vagrancy
in Utah okay and I'm gonna come back to
this person because I do a micro history
for this personally BC he was born in
Purcell so his father went to prison
when he was four years old his mother
remarried which he says made his life
miserable and so he began running away
aged 11 years old and then he went to
reformatory school and so what important
things here that I want to
is that running away from home it's
actually a gift to law it's a crime so
in other words these youth are fugitives
once they leave home they're actually
under the threat of being incarcerated
or sent to State Reformatory schools so
essential estate and former Tory school
he gets out and eventually he just runs
away to California Sacramento and even
gets to labor in the farm fields of
Sacramento at 14 years old and so if we
can imagine a 14-year old also running
away all the way to Sacramento and he
runs away in around nineteen thirty four
so this is the Great Depression okay and
this is a micro history of this person
James Smith and James Smith is a
migration patterns Pollock attract and
I'll tell you why so I'll introduce you
just there's a little
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the party
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so I'm a scroll past that and just come
to James's migration pattern and so one
thing also so think about California why
California and is this a track so
California is like many other places
have vagrancy laws and vagrancy law is
criminalized people in public places
like young people african-americans at
this time other groups are racialized
different so you have people like
Italians you have like sex workers all
these different issues to counteract
people's presence and so in California
you could be charged with vagrancy for
being unemployed you can be charged with
agency for being homeless you could be
charged with vagrancy from roaming from
place to place so all of these things
created a trap for an itinerant laborer
like James and so these yellow marks
right here is so we mapped nineteen
people from the archives who had
vagrancy charges all across the country
so in 37 different cities we found
people through records in California
that were arrested for vagrancy charges
across the country and so at this time
41 states have vagrancy charges and at
least 37 have vagrancy charges for those
who are unemployed and so you can
imagine someone who is in harvest labor
that's very seasonal and what it's like
to be in California at a time and so
James was in California in the Great
Depression so you have foreign labor
strikes going on
have southwestern migrants so you have
like this entire migration campaign that
went on and so this right here also with
a very interactive thing so this is you
can overlay it with the railroads and as
you can see the closer you get you see
the railroads you see like these
different places like James was arrested
here in Toulon these arrests are right
here in Imperial Valley and the closer
you kind of get in you can see different
you can see California where it's not
just a blur but these are different
places that uh people are being
criminalized and so the reason why the
image is important is this map right
here shows us how unsettling was and so
as James are going to go up into
California and laboring he's going into
places and he's being charged with
vagrancy ending being kicked out of that
region and so then he goes to another
region and then he's charged at Vegas
again and then he'd kicked out and so
James Lee first commits a burglary
because he said he needed food to eat
he's given 15 years probation and he's
given one year on a road camp and then
told to leave the state and never come
back
so James is up coming back and being
charged with vagrancy again and then he
sent back to LA County because of
probation violation because remember
he's kicked out of state for 15 years so
then he ends up coming back and as you
can see something pulling him up into
the farms of California but he keeps
being kicked out for vagrancy and he I
was like this 15 year sentence over his
head and so eventually he comes back and
of course it's a great migration I miss
the Great Depression and so he's caught
up in this trap and the importance of
trying to really articulate migrants who
will come from other states is that once
you get arrested and sent to prison
there's family estrangement there's no
phone to call home and some of these
young people hadn't seen their parents
in over 14 years and the first time they
were able to even sit down and write a
letter to a family may have been 10 or
15 years later when they were in prison
because their lives were so precarious
and a lot of times they were under the
threat of not only vagrancy charges but
also just being just roaming through
different places and so it's very
important I think to shed light on young
people's narratives because they weren't
wrong
fathers and mothers they were alone so
they had to find food and a lot of times
many of the public spaces are very
criminalized and so the mapping part
helped me kind of understand the agra
fees of survival and trying to better
understand how different people survive
being on a road without the families and
also under the threat of increased
surveillance increased incarceration and
well as the criminalization of poverty
and so it's not only just black youth
that are being criminalized it's pretty
much a lot of poor youth during a Great
Depression particularly and so the black
story is very important because in
California we don't typically hear about
black migrant laborers in the harvest
field and also much of the great
migration that talks about
african-americans in California is close
to the lens of middle class and other
people who we can trace their lives you
can't trace their lives with people who
are poor or who are always constantly
moving because of the surveillance of
police or because you couldn't be
homeless in public and so putting traces
of their lives together product the
conversation about the great migration
and so this is a part of a larger
project to link with migration in this
thank you
[Applause]
thanks for that wonderful presentation
next we have Rachel on and Jake will a
volte who were going to speaking to us
about preserving history and memory
databasing American public sculptures
yeah so Jake and I are going to talk to
a lot of American public sculptures and
the work we've been doing in that area
so this is an introduction
Jake and I last semester took this grade
class with Professor Laura Wexler which
was inaugural course in Yale University
and Smithsonian partnership so it was a
really cool class you got access to
their favorite outdoor sculpture
database which was started in the 1990s
and it was a very big like public
initiative almost for 7,000 volunteers
collected information of other community
sculptures and it was to generate
appreciation enthusiasm and just a
general sense of preservation for what
we have so that was really cool but they
found that more than 32,000 public
sculptures needed conservation or
maintenance and also what we found
looking through their data was
furthermore that most of the work was
under 90s so there was immaculate
technology for quality for photos and
the sculptures have moved since then so
after the class is over
we precise take on this project where we
update it and also see what more we can
do with it with today's technology great
so I'm going to talk a little bit about
the sort of processes that we've been
using to actually make this data into
something that is usable and
visualizable for us by us for the
community the first thing that we're
using is cartodb we are having an active
database about every hour when we're
updating our database it pushes to this
live map which we'll show you in a
little bit which basically shows you
where the sculpture is exactly who
sculpted it when it was sculpted any
historical facts that might be important
to it and
placing that on the map as Rachel said a
lot of these places were not a lot of
sculptures did not have the correct
coordinates as it was done in the early
90s we found this when we were looking
at the sculptures in New Haven and 47
sculptures were in the exact same spot
we knew something wasn't exactly correct
the second thing that we're working on
doing too is also taking some of these
sculptures and making 3d models with
them both for conservation and for
preservation this is not a public
sculptures this is the Clark Memorial in
the Grove Street Cemetery and what we're
doing is creating some 3d models and ads
of soft photos can and meshlab taking
these sort of 3d photogrammetry
softwares and making them as accessible
as possible for showing folks that like
hey what this project was in the 90s you
could use it now you can make a fully
rotating and printable 3d sculpture of
things that you have in your community
that you care so much about yeah so next
up is the SOS so what we've been doing
currently is orienting the database with
the public in mind so just two screen
shots the top is what the Smithsonian
gave us so I too was it was kind of
counterintuitive they gave us creator
one which is a sculptor create 32 if
there's a second sculpture the Creator
firm and then the title alternate title
stay dimensions and then locations way
on after and most people don't really
care about who the creators were unless
they're big-name cultures so what we've
been doing is we've made the title of
those sculptures first so we have some
small war memorial a month you'll see it
they type it in as the first thing and
then we gave them the location the exact
coordinate and the first two columns is
just for us only I have to worry about
it and what's really great is for
example the New Haven County Courthouse
they have five sculptures around it so
two on the front and three on the side
so if you are interested in seeing it we
give them the exact size and exact
location where they are and the second
thing is you're talking about during a
project to reach greater awareness so
maybe that's 3d printing some of our
favorite sculptures that we have around
us or maybe that's creating an
application that people can have on
their phone to see where these things
are go get it and take a personal note
all right so hopefully this oh oh no
yeah we'll do this and so I want to walk
y'all through the map real quick I don't
think listen oh cool Oh No okay so we're
working on cleaning this up a little bit
as you can see there's sort of all just
popping up now but let's say we want to
look at the children it's not where Oh
No here we go great okay so you see it
pops up here you get the location on the
physical map the sculptor the medium and
when it was sculpted and what this is is
great for is one not only eventually
making this more public as you can see I
think from our data as well the
Smithsonian while it was a public
project dot that data sort of for
themselves I think you can tell in the
way the data was oriented for us and
sort of trying to take that public data
that was collected by seven thousand
volunteers and making it again more
public consumption so part of the
creation of this map is to do that and
secondly it allows to sort of see
sculptural trends and so one thing I was
really surprised about it doesn't see
this on my computer all right there's a
huge cluster that you can see right here
and I was talking to Rachel no that
can't be right
right they can't all be in the same spot
turns out there's this great thing and a
pretty small town in Connecticut called
Monument
was it a monumental of our money a
boulevards a bunch of war memorials on
it right these are something that we
would not have known because the data
was kind of fudged before we started
touching it let's jump back into this
PowerPoint so that's our mouth if you
wanted to talk a little bit as well just
sort of why nope
why the sort of thing is important sir
Richie once I start though disculpa yeah
so one of the first things is updating
it and one of the sculptor's listed in
Connecticut with this Bank of Discobolus
by Robert Cronin and I was looking for
and I can find it anywhere decided
Google search of it and in 2007 I found
this newsletter for women college called
the fountain where they talked about how
they have this grand new like new
sculpture and how they were so excited
about it so it's actually a Walla Walla
Washington right now and the movement
took happens about a decade ago but
hasn't been noted so just small things
like that like the movement of
sculptures is really common and also
just a lot of updating so forth that's
been done I love that I left there's a
turn for this point it on this slideshow
anyway talking a little bit again about
what the difference between private and
public actually means and what public
means and for whom when we're thinking
about the sort of politics of the space
that exists we have a place like Yale
whose sculptures are on this database
but whose campus is not actually truly
public sure anyone can go see habakkuk
by WH any point of time but they're not
Wedge the sort of same permanence that
sculptures have and so making sure that
they're on this database to make them
more public also to have them be tracked
so that again they can't just move it to
Washington and the system Oni doesn't
find out for 22 here 25 years until we
of people who are looking at this data
and the Smithsonian had no ideas this
wasn't a in Connecticut the they're also
moving the Calder that's by Commons
right and so when we take something but
very very public like the colder that's
outside of Commons and move that because
when it's becoming the Schwartzman
Center they're like digging and building
glass they're saluting the camus they're
moving the Calder where is that going to
go right the importance of having a
database like this is to say we know
where it is now and if it's long as it's
being constantly updated it will always
be available to the public or else we'd
risk it not being public and moving into
the private realm when it's on pride
property we found a lot of sculptures
that have not only been moved but also
been destroyed there was a school that
was sold to a private company became a
nursing home and they actually tore down
a sculpture because they thought it was
ugly that Salters gone now and again
this wasn't something that was known for
25 years and the last thing is that when
there is such a big risk of cuts to our
security funding with the NHA and the
neh all of these sorts of things mean
that it's always more and more important
to make sure that the public is
experiencing these sculptures this
public art and also getting people
engaged in the art that is in their
communities but also simultaneously
letting people decide what art is
important in their communities having a
database that is accessible and
buildable by the people who live in
particular places allows them to also
add to this to visit sculptures within
their community to appreciate them and
to care for them
that's just think yeah so thank you to
Laura Beck's clear the mantra here this
morning but it's really amazing
wonderful visionary woman Katherine
dubrow's thank you so much for just like
letting us you're here where are you oh
you're like there for just letting us
like occupy the DEA slab like all the
time and in Stefan Simone and goes deco
glia for their help with the sort of I
just opted meshlab portion thank you
[Music]
wonderful thanks to Rachel and Jake so
next I'd like to invite up a trio of
presenters Elizabeth Cokie yet Ivy Lee
and Julia Toph and we're going to
speaking on process and context the
characterization of pictorialist
photographs using raking light imaging
and x-ray fluorescence spectra see there
you go okay so hi I'm Ivy this is
Elizabeth and Julia and we'll be
presenting on us Kristen sectorial is
photography project so the objective of
our project was to scientifically
determined verify or correct the
identification of photographic processes
and a collection of 74 graphic prints
from the early 19th late 19th and early
20th century before photographs were
photographic processes were visually
determined and we wanted a more
scientific accurate way to determine and
identified the photographic processes so
what is for tourist photography
pictorial photography was a movement
that sought to elevate photography as
more of an art form and not just a tool
for recording history and current white
whose photographs we were analyzing in
this project was a leading proponent of
a pictorial ISM and he was a teacher who
actually trained many of the leading
photographers during this time and his
collections were a part of the Princeton
University art collection and we did
this project on behalf of an exhibition
that they had at their Princeton Art
Museum
so the types of photography that we
looked at in our project included gum
gum bichromate cyano type platinum and
palladium and these processes all have
different chemical compositions specific
to specific to the type of process and
as you can see a lot of these processes
you can sort of visually determine for
example if I know type is
characteristically blue but for example
with platinum and palladium you really
can't tell the difference just by
looking at it so a lot of what we sought
to do was to really distinguish these
different types of prints so the way
that we went about determining the
processes scientifically was through a
technology called x-ray fluorescence or
XRF
and how it works is that we have the
x-ray gun that we pointed at the print
and the actually going to irritate
x-rays that would excite the electrons
in an inner in the inner orbitals of an
atom and this would expect the electrons
and dislodge it and so in order to
regain stability the atom would were
still in the vacancy that the electron
left with an electron from an outer
shell and when this happened this
release and energy that was equivalent
to the difference in the quantum and the
quantum shells that the electron was
moving between and this was very surface
energy different is very specific to two
different types of elements and by doing
this we were able to determine which
type of elements were it were include or
were involved in the different
photographs that we were analyzing so
this is what the data readout from x RF
measurements looks like so as you can
see there's different peaks and they
correspond to specific elements so in
order for us to determine elements that
were actually part of the imaging
material rather than part of
paper or other supports we had to take
two measurements for each print one in
the demon area which you would know is
just the lightest part of image which
has the smallest amount of imaging
material and one in the d-max or darkest
part of the image which has the most
imaging material so you can see that he
mass measurement is the dark blue on
this and the demon is the light blue
so when there is a big difference in the
amount of an element in the d-max of the
demon that's an indication that the
element is part of the actual imaging
material so you can see here I've
labeled the bits that were in the
imaging material for this particular
print and you can see the principal
elements were chromium and iron which
are characteristic of a gun dichromate
print so that's how we identified this
one and this is an example of a
palladium press which actually this is
one of the ones that was falsely
identified as platinum but then we
changed the identification to Palladia
so palladium and mercury are
characteristic of this type of print and
then also just to point out the elements
or founding paper itself are also
important to record because it's also
information about materials the artist
used so these elements here are ones
that were found in the paper of this
print and then so we tested 70 prints
and out of that 422 of the prints we
identified a medium that was different
than the one that had been identified
visually so you could call that an error
rate in the catalog of 31% if you're
able to correct in addition to looking
at the chemical makeup of the
photographs we wanted to gain a better
understanding of the specific types of
paper particular to clearance lights
photography so we use microscopy
techniques and image processing and
pattern recognition algorithms to find
clusters of similar paper across time
periods so these are the raw images we
captured of a one centimeter section of
each photographs in the lightest area of
the
photographs least affected by different
photographic materials and we process
the images to remove the influences
color and get these more normalized
images that we can compare between each
other to find patterns in the texture so
we created an affinity chart of well we
created an affinity size and we were
able to find clusters of similar types
of textures in the paper and we use this
data to compare the chemical makeup the
chemical makeup we got from xrs data to
the physical data that we got from the
microscopy data and we can use this
baseline of data to categorize
photographic prints and other
institutions can use this data as well
so this is art it's going to be chart
and you can see the areas of high
affinity in which we found similar
textures and significance and our
acknowledgments so um we'd like to thank
Annika Bezier Pablo and arrow and Paul
Messier who are here today who helped
organize this project and led us through
a lot of the science behind it as well
as the historical significance and we
don't feel like to make the other
students who worked along with us in
this project
Jacob obey Colin Hema and Rachel on who
were here today and Rachel and Jake
actually just prevent some presented
before us and we'd also like to thank
two professors the graduate students and
the curators at at the Princeton
University Art Museum who who let us
work on their photographs and Jonathan
who is also here and was the West Campus
communications officer thank you
[Applause]
wonderful thank you to Elizabeth IV and
Julia our life preventer will be summer
Sutton will be presenting on the mine
design tool and so I'm going to be
talking about the mine design tool which
is a brain-computer interface that I'm
developing as part of a Yale HP blended
realities grant that I received this
academic year I'm a first year
architecture PhD student here and before
coming to Yale I was an architect and as
a designer our primary goal is to
translate information that comes from
imaginary visions creative processes and
turn it into the physical reality it's
very hard to actually translate that
information when the way people view
objects and symbols is very subjective
dependent on cultural interpretations
and exposure the way I'm trying to
leapfrog this objectivity and design is
going directly to neurological activity
and translating that data into a 3d form
the way I'm approaching it is using an
EEG brain scanner
this is the real the real one now these
EEG brain scanners are a lot more
consumer-friendly
you can see that they're about 14
channels that read different parts of
the brain in many labs the EEG brain
headset uses a lot more nodes but this
allows us to at least experiment on a
consumer level in the same way that you
know 3d printers are being more made
more accessible through more economic
means and simplification so this is a
great start to manipulating data that
comes from neurological activity
looking at a kind of unconscious
collective understanding of forms and
lines psychologically associated with
emotions I'm trying to develop this idea
of based on a user being able to
manipulate the the development of a form
through their own chosen type of stimuli
that will create some sort of cognitive
activity and I have a quick video that
explains the process of creating a form
using the EEG brain scanner
[Music]
when the EEG
[Music]
[Music]
based on a user's self-reporting
collecting information from collecting
data with emotional responses we can
create a program that can manipulate a
form in a way and it's Mexican to
possible emotional reaction or decline
working with a basic block I'm many
planning points on the blocks and x y&z
axis based on the degree of variance the
data that's being keeping us collected
by the EEG brain and using Python where
it wills you
manipulate that form
[Music]
and in that form could be 3d printed
[Music]
you have an object
they're an object and physically
represent what is happening comments
weekly in your mind and I was proposing
that you could create gifts for people
that represent your emotional reaction
to any sort of stimuli and a person can
physically hold a representation of your
ideas and thoughts and feelings as this
actually applies to what I really want
to talk about today with architecture
and conservation what would happen in
the opposite effect instead of building
building physical objects from
neurological data what is the think of
the imagination as a void and so we're
not building based on the imagination
but we're taking away based on the
imagination and the reason I think this
is important is because we have been
concerned recently over the destruction
of historical monuments in Syria and
Iraq and what does it mean to be
actually concerned about that removal of
a physical object that we may never
actually see in our only connection with
those objects is through images in text
books or images that you see online so
why are we so affected by its physical
destruction in a place that we may never
go to if you were walking into the room
you might have seen on in the hallway
there's been a previous project that 3d
prints the ruins of Palmyra and that's
used as an example of how 3d printing
can help educate people about these
monuments that you may never get see or
that are eventually destroyed I'm
looking at this wall in Nineveh Iraq as
just an example this wall has been
destroyed and people are of course
concerned over the destruction of the
cultural heritage monument but of course
in the history of this monument has been
stride plenty of times by various powers
that are taking trying to take over
control
so if destruction really something that
we're trying to constantly embrace when
it's something that constantly happens
or do we accept it as part of the
heritage in the history of the physical
object the destruction is a of physical
bill of architectural monument even on
Oahu's video you can find it online as
well if you want to watch it later
it talks about this work as well so the
beautification of ruins and destruction
has been constantly into the 18th
century we have a fascination with them
as a indication of time that's passed
it's indication of man versus nature and
the physical reality of conflict in
terms of 3d printing there are a lot of
benefits in 3d printing in areas of
conflict and in reconstruction
especially in rock or Syria the creation
and prosthetics as well as other tools
and devices that are developed to create
or to provide areas with limited
resources with unique objects that will
help rebuild the area and recover from
from the conflict in terms of
architecture what can we do with 3d
printing to help these areas of homes
Lloyd
and so I decided to redesign my Python
coding and tool to be able to manipulate
a Brit a simple but very quick to be
used for the reconstruction of a
monument and with the concept of
removing a solid the use of them EEG
brain scanner 10 based on the stimuli
manipulate this block so in that when
you start off with this block in the end
you can 3d print a block that represents
the dorks imagine association with a
monument your memory of the past of the
monument so it's an embodied sense of
time sense of association with about the
architecture element so in the end you
can have a wall that is a mixture of the
original material as well as the blocks
of of embodied meaning from the the
universe that feels impacted by the loss
of the physical object of the monument
and in the end I think that we can
propose that we can turn this into
something that's kind of like
Kickstarter with Cuba where when we want
to build an object or rebuild a monument
it can be posted on a crowdsourcing
website and for people who want to
donate and be part of the reconstruction
of these martinas instead of just giving
money away the donor actually gets to
individually have an impact on the
physical construction of it by
submitting their EEG data that
manipulates the form and on the site it
can be 3d printed and become part of the
reconstruction of the monument so as a
donor
you're not only contributing financially
but you feel a sense of ownership and an
object in the physical presence and
exploitation and this is just an example
of a kind of wall and the kind of
versatility you get from the
manipulation of these blocks and when I
put together as a collective cognition
of the past
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]
you
[Music]